sie haben gerade schon wird er
angesprochen sie haben auch andere
unternehmer angesprochen wie
beispielsweise einzelhändler christian
hartmann ist einzelhändler aus weinstadt
bei stuttgart und uns zu gestaltet
ebenso zugeschaltet hans eder der hat
eine kartbahn in altötting in der alten
heimat des papstes und fragt dies die
klasse sonst zu gestaltet der ein
gastronom aus bad friedrichshall ist das
ist in der nähe von heilbronn werden sie
vielleicht kennen wo nicht ganz so ganz
so weit entfernt davon hält meyer und
beginnen wollen wir mit ihnen hartmann
schönen guten abend auch bei ihnen
einmal die frage nach ihrer ganz
persönlichen corona rechnung
einzelhändler modegeschäft in weinstadt
bei stuttgart wir erstmal katastrophal
man kann es wirklich ein anderes
zusammenfassen
wir kämpfen wirklich um jeden euro
umsatz sehen wir auch im geschlossenen
zustand machen können und ich habe mir
die zahlen auch veröffentlicht um die
transparenz zu schaffen und auch einfach
mal darzustellen was wirklich an hilfen
zurück kommen ich weiß nicht ob sie's
einspielen können wir können einmal ganz
kurz zeigen sie hatten wir uns einmal
ihre kassen zahlen sozusagen vorab zur
verfügung gestellt
vielleicht können sie einmal selbst
erläutern er hat man also umsatzverluste
in den corona zeiten das betrifft wie
viel monate bei ihm
das betrifft tatsächlich den kompletten
lockdown bis 31 erst mitte dezember und
ist betrifft den ersten lockdown von
mitte märz bis mitte april die
umsatzzahlen die da veröffentlicht ist
tatsächlich auch nur für den lockdown
der umsatzverlust und im vergleich zum
pro jahr gesetzt und man sieht mit 8,43
prozent wie die solidarität von unserem
bundeswirtschaftsminister wirklich
aussieht
ja darf ich eine frage stellen sie
stellt nicht stets habe ich etliche
hilfen bekommen von 17.600 euro
da sind ja vermutlich noch nach kräften
dabei die sie bekommen werden vom 15
dezember bis solange der lok dann dauert
denn da wird er die antragsstellung erst
jetzt im februar möglich sein
das ist teilweise richtig es ist nämlich
so dass wir für dezember nicht
anspruchsberechtigt sind weil wir keine
30 prozent umsatzminus erwirtschaftet
haben weil es eher nicht den
schließungszeit raum als grundlage
nehmen sondern den ganzen dezember das
müssen sie bau noch einmal erklären wie
das möglich ist und dadurch gibt es für
dezember
das ist richtig dass die januar zahlen
fehlen die momentan nicht mal beantragt
was sie tragen sie meinen steuerberater
was er ihm zu ihren überbrückungshilfen
desaster eigentlich sagen will also die
wissen wo inzwischen nicht mehr was sie
da genau machen sollen diesmal hat soll
die faq es ist ein wirklich ein
heilloses durcheinander und bürokratie
ohne ende das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen dass sie sich im moment
erraten wie finanzieren sie sich im
moment hat man ja ja der staat zwingt
mich dazu mich zu verschulden und zwar
ganz einfach nur eine bank sagt mir also
hör mal zu hört man ja du kriegst jetzt
eine viertelmillion neuware die kannst
du nicht abstellen weil die erste von
neun bis zwölf monaten schon bestellt
die trudelt jetzt eins gesehen das ist
ungefähr der betrag der mehr an umsatz
verloren gegangen ist aus dem betrag
bezahlt ich das ganze normalerweise kann
ich jetzt nicht jetzt habe ich die
möglichkeit entweder ich melde insolvenz
an oder ich nehme staatliche kredite auf
die sich der staat mit drei prozent
verzinsen lässt und das heißt ich selber
zu 0,6 prozent aufnehmen
das heißt er hat man sagte altmaier die
bundesregierung hat sich zum schuldner
gemacht
ja das gab es ja ganz das gilt für ganz
viele unternehmen die 80 milliarden die
wir zur verfügung gestellt haben
davon sind ungefähr ungefähr die hälfte
darlehen die wir über die kreditanstalt
für wiederaufbau kfw gegeben haben an
die unternehmen und das hat etwas zu tun
auch mit den regeln der europäischen
union über staatliche beihilfen die für
alle mitgliedstaaten gelten
das sind leute bei denen das geschäft
lief die schulden gemacht haben die gut
dastanden und die jetzt sagen
der start der großen hat mich zum
schuldner ich weiß aber es gibt es gibt
natürlich auch ganz viele arbeiten
immerhin geht es genauso das sind die
die jetzt in der kurzarbeit sind und
weniger netto nach hause bringen als die
ganze zeit und wenn zwei und frau in
zwei ehepartner in kurzarbeit sind dann
fehlt manchmal viel fest haben die
hineinkommen wir hatten eine
wirtschaftsschrumpfung im letzten jahr
von fünf prozent und das hat eben nicht
alle getroffen ist gibt welche die haben
gut verdient im lebensmitteleinzelhandel
in der industrie in anderen bereichen
haben die umsätze sogar geboomt zum teil
und andere haben deshalb mehr als fünf
prozent die haben zehn 20 30 40
rückgänge und das ist das ist wirklich
dramatisch für die betroffenen aber wir
haben nur in einem einzigen fall gesagt
dass wir umsatzverluste erstatten
das waren all die geschäfte die wir
schon am ersten november geschlossen
haben und auch nur für die monate
november und dezember
die bekommen 75 prozent ihres
ausgefallenen umsatz her jeder wie lange
hat ihre kartbahn jetzt dicht wie lange
es da kein betrieb
die geschlossen nach genommen jetzt sein
erster november wieder geschossen ich
habe 35 mitarbeiter im november noch
beschäftigt weil wir uns ja geeinigt
haben auf einen sehr kurzen knackigen
lockt uns versprochen wurde
da wird ja auch wieder entsprechend
bietet was natürlich nicht stattgefunden
hat ganz deutlich
im moment geht so man umsatzausfall seit
dem beginn ihrer plan bmi von 550.000
euro bisher erhaltenen hilfen vielen
dank herr altmaier 38.000 euro
natürlich hilft das da habe ich es nur
ein tropfen auf einen heißen stein und
eher steinig mehr heinz den wir zu
zerreißen
ich sage ihnen das mal ganz deutlich
betreiben wenn die kartons hat 96 liebe
dieses geschäft nicht wegen der renditen
nicht wegen den hoch setzen
ich liebe es wegen den kontakt zu den
menschen wie in den sozialen umfeld und
weil ich motorsport vom markt war schon
für kinder und auch für erwachsene das
dann ganz malen einfach begleiten können
einfach schön finde
und ich möchte mein geschäft nicht
beenden ich habe meine gesamte
altersversorgung ich von meiner frau und
von mir nun bereits wieder ins geschäft
gesteckt die hatte ich mir eigentlich
seit 1996 hart gearbeitet wir haben
nicht die fetten renditen wenn sie 75
prozent wie im november vom umsatz
anbieten
dann wäre das ein sehr hilfreicher
ansatz gewesen aber wenn es irgendwann
so ruhig dass ihr dann viele dinge hinab
zu kommen wie die kurzarbeiter geld
kosten und solche sachen
und wir haben eine endeffekt merken dass
wir in etwa auf eine quote von 23
prozent kommen die wir dann vom umsatz
haben dann passiert mir nicht mal in
einen bereich wo wir uns dagegen wie was
schaffen könnten dass uns dann über die
zeit bringt in der arbeit weit von der
bundesregierung einfach kein geld kommt
wir sehen eine zahlung einer ganz ganz
langsam ein hund alleine das dass sie
vor allem auf sein ja für die anderen
können sie ja noch gar keine
anfangs stellen gekürzt sie hasst dem
vorstellen der entschuldung sie müssen
sich dafür schämen antragstellung das
wäre ganz einfach hören
die können dann erster tag funktioniert
ja ich also erst einmal entschuldige ich
mich dafür
das ist mir wirklich ernst dass es so
lange dauert
zweitens können sie mir glauben wenn ich
irgend eine möglichkeit gesehen hätte es
zu beschleunigen ich hätte es gemacht
und ich werde zum fuß gelaufen bis zu
ihrer kartbahn aber tatsache ist dass
die bundesländer die die hilfen des
bundes ausführen und verwalten und die
beamten zur verfügung stellen in ihrem
förderbanken uns erklärt haben sie sehen
sich außerstande die überbrückungshilfen
und die und die umsatz erstattungen
november/dezember helfen was die anträge
angeht die aufnahme und die bearbeitung
zunächst zu administrieren
der finanzminister ging ihrem
umsatzausfälle und die
länderfinanzminister haben gesagt wir
können es auch nicht über die
finanzämter machen und wir haben dann
eine lösung aus dem boden gestampft
quasi über nacht wo wir über eine
internetplattform die plattform eine
überbrückungshilfe de
diese dinge organisieren und das muss
programmiert werden weil nämlich jede
bedingung ja gelöst werden muss und
jetzt sage ich ihnen wir haben bei den
überbrückungshilfen ab januar haben wir
bis vor wenigen tagen bestritten auch
mit dem kollegen im und diskutiert mit
dem kollegen im finanzministerium weil
immer wieder menschen kommen und sagen
ihr müsst das noch machen ihr habt das
vergessen das ist so ungünstig das geht
nicht und sie können aber erst anfangen
wenn das alles feststeht wie sollen denn
die beamten wissen was sie auszahlen
wenn die einzelnen bedingungen noch
nicht geklärt sind und das ist etwas wo
wir zu schwerfällig sind wo wir
schneller werden müssen und wo wir
hoffentlich lernen wenn wir das nächste
mal in einer ähnlichen situation sind
ich will die sache mit den kurzarbeiter
noch aufklären
also wir haben gesagt sie kriegen 75
prozent vom umsatz den sie im letzten
jahr im november und im dezember hatten
und natürlich
haben sie damals ihre mitarbeiter
bezahlt und das war teil ihres umsatzes
und jetzt sind die in kurzarbeit und
dann bekommen die ja ihre bezahlung von
der bundesagentur
und deshalb wird es abgezogen ansonsten
wäre es ja eine über kommt ganz schnell
räder wie finanzieren sie sich im moment
hatten sie irgendwelche rücklagen die
sie anzapfen konnten und jetzt mussten
oder komplett aufgezehrt oder dienste
als begonnen und sind auch kurz vor aber
ich wollte ja schon einmal kurz darauf
eingehen ich kann das schon rechnen
ich verstehe auf den abzug aber mir ist
es wichtig dass einmal deutlich zu sagen
wissen sie ich stresse auf den straßen
und menschen die mich sagen oh ist das
schön
fast 75 prozent vom umsatz euch jetzt
richtig gut aus die gastronomie hat
wirklich ein schnäppchen gemacht und das
ist auch so ein blöder man von der fdp
in der talkshow und erzählt den leuten
wie sich die gastronomen letzten einfach
machen mit den 75 prozent warum nehmen
sie dann so eine zahl in den mund in der
realität gar nicht stattfindet und ganz
ehrlich noch mal ich spreche jetzt aus
meiner situation heraus ich ärgere mich
dass pressionen im norden aufgeben
müssen ich finde das schlimm
man könne die nicht viel helfen da es
oft nur ein kleines zelt das könnten
sogar kommunal erledigt werden auch mal
ganz einstellen eben dazu kommen nicht
so ideen und einen wirtschaftsminister
stadt eine wirtschaftlich starke weil
wirtschaftsminister würde kämpfen
kämpfen dafür dass die firmen arbeiten
können und ich wieder neuregelung sich
einfallen lassen wie man die noch
ausblenden zu haben und noch mehrere
mutationen warum ist denn zu sein muss
sie sind ja der für uns ist die
bundesligisten die frau merkel herr
söder land und leuten die uns alles
suchen wollen genau das ist der punkt
der bei vielen unternehmen bleibt haben
sie wirklich bis jetzt haben sie bis
zuletzt alles menschenmögliche gefragt
das sein geld bekommen hat dass er sein
geld bekommt aber aber natürlich es gibt
kein land in europa das ähnlich viel
geld bereits ausgezahlt hat wie
deutschland es gibt kein einziges nicht
frankreich nicht italien nicht mehr
selbst zu langsam als sich darin
entschuldigt ja natürlich aber ich kann
doch ich kann doch nicht ich kann doch
nicht den bundesrechnungshof die gesetze
die gerichte alles außer kraft setzen
und sagen hier kommt wir machen aber sie
haben gerade gesagt die länder sind am
ende jetzt zu langsam in dem verfahren
das hat uns ja langsam ein ich weiß ich
ich ich verteile keine nicht an die
länder sich noch andere ministerien
annehmen
ich sage ja ich sage ich verstehe doch
ich verstehe noch ihre enttäuschung ich
versteh's nicht auch aber sehen sie mal
20 stunden am tag arbeiten und sagen man
muss ich schlafen das heißt ich kann ich
kann am wochenende arbeiten ich kann ich
kann wie es nachts arbeiten aber
trotzdem kann niemand die welt verändern
und das prinzip dass man eben nicht
sagen kann wir geben jetzt einfach mal
jedem 50.000 oder 100.000 euro das
dürfen wir nicht durch die eu wir müssen
alles genehmigen lassen
ich habe mit dem musiker stolz zusammen
das versprechen das versprechen der
ärgert herren das versprechen der ärger
denn jeder so wahnsinnig das versprechen
ein als die bauern noch geschadet habe
dir die leute über das jahr macht sich
ja ich kann es kurzfristig weiter jena
ist aber die bazooka
das war in einem konkreten situation hat
der stolz gesagt jeder kriegt einen
kredit der den kredit haben will und
dann haben die banken gesagt uns reichen
die sicherheit nicht und dann haben wir
den 800.000 euro sofortkredit gemacht wo
der bund 100 prozent der haftung
übernächsten halt november hilfe und
konnten die besucher ja gar nicht
verwandt ich halte dann muss ich ihnen
sagen ich habe nie gesagt es stoff sich
jemand die taschen voll mit der umsatz
erstattung oder er hat ein geschenk
bekommen nein wir haben doch die umsatz
erstattung gemacht weil wir sie für
notwendig
das war immerhin 375 vom umsatz haben
einige leute gesagt hoher der
gastronomie geht's aber richtig gut
sich jetzt dafür auf der straße
verteidigung das wird der gegner ist
wahrscheinlich auch canon mit seinem
nord bahnhöfle gegners vermutlich genau
dieselben probleme oder sind sie
mittlerweile an die helfen gekommen
also ich gibt es gerade hier und
schüttelt so ein bisschen den kopf weil
man jetzt genau in den gesprächen mehr
oder
es ist halt sehr viel versprochen worden
es ist gleich zu anfang sehr viel
versprochen worden um wahrscheinlich
auch die leute zu beruhigen weil
natürlich alle angst hatten was ist
jetzt los mit dem wenn wir alle
schließen müssen man verdiene geld und
dann hieß es natürlich von
regierungsseite eher keine sorgen
kümmern uns um ihr bekommen ganz schnell
hilfen und solche kleinwort nie ganz
schnell
ja da ist man natürlich dann hellhörig
und ihr team ja was das dilemma ist die
wolken sitzen da auch lea gastronom und
warten ob die versprochenen menschen die
abschlagen seinem restaurant von der
hamas
diese haben sagt die abschlagszahlungen
sind zum teil gekommen oder noch nicht
gekommen
zum teil geht ja okay und marcell was
und man hat die versprechen gegeben um
zu beruhigen um vielleicht auch sich
selber zu beruhigen und zu sagen mensch
da haben wir jetzt ein riesen aufstand
im land dann werden die nämlich schon
alle im november sauer gewesen wenn sie
es nicht versprochen hätten also und
jetzt sehen sie dass die hilfen nicht
gekommen sind oder zum teil gekommen
sind und merken halte an den anderen
machen das ja nur für mich sagen ist ja
es werden ja jeden tag hunderte
interviews gemacht
von allen möglichen beteiligten ich habe
immer gesagt wir werden bei den november
hilfen dafür sorgen dass noch im
november die anträge gestellt werden
das war am 25 der fall und wir werden
noch im november beginnen mit den
abschlagszahlungen das war am 27
der fall und wir haben inzwischen von
den beantragten november hilfen 3
milliarden ausgezahlt beantragt sind
insgesamt fünf milliarden
und zwar nicht nur abschlagszahlungen
sondern seit drei wochen sind die länder
jetzt wieder dran und es wird
abgewickelt und wird ausbezahlt und ich
gehe davon
aus dass wir sehr schnell die
fortschritte machen aber ich verstehe
auch und deshalb ich bin doch nicht der
gegner von denen die hier zugeschaltet
und ich bin in der tat deren anwalt ich
verstehe doch wenn man auf glühenden
kohlen sitzt und darauf wartet dass das
geld kommt dass jeder tag ein tag so
lange ist und deshalb habe ich ja auch
gesagt mir tut das von herzen leid aber
es war bisher von all den kritikern noch
nie noch keiner da ich rede ist nicht
von ihnen ich rede von denen die auch in
der politik dann denke da kann die
opposition mal gesagt haben das ist ja
eigentlich noch weitere auch in ihm ist
dass er gesagt hat wie es schneller geht
war noch niemand da der gesagt hat wie
es schneller und das ist ja eigentlich
noch bitterer ja das ist ja noch dadurch
funktioniert erst rechtlich dass es
nicht rationiert wenn man vorher was ich
hoffe ich habe ja mancher bund habe ja
angebot habe gesagt passt auf ich gebe
euch das gerne ab wenn ihr das wollt und
ihr glaubt ihr kriegt das geld schneller
an die frauen an den mann dann könnt ihr
das tun
über sparkassen und raiffeisenbanken und
volksbanken über die kommunen über die
finanzämter es hat sich niemand gemeldet
und niemand darum gerissen und wir haben
diesen job übernommen war nicht zutiefst
davon überzeugt bin dass eine frage der
gerechtigkeit ist dass wir das geld zu
den menschen bringen und als uns dann
klar geworden ist dass es in einzelnen
fällen halt eben dann auch dauert bis
ende februar vielleicht sogar bis in den
märz bis alles erledigt ist sind wir
hingegangen und haben gesagt dann darf
aber niemand in der zeit heißt von der
schneller als das wirtschaftsministerium
schneller als das finanzministerium das
ja auch zuständig ist hätte niemand
hingekriegt es hat jedenfalls niemand
sich gemeldet und es hat uns auch
niemand versucht herr gegner ist ganz
kurze abschlussrunde mit ihnen drei
betätigen das gehen sie davon aus dass
sie im sommer das ist ja die perspektive
von herrn altmaier gewesen wenn die
sonne wieder scheint dann könnte es
wieder so weit sein dass die restaurants
dass die gastronomie wieder eröffnet
gehen sie davon aus dass die geschäfte
noch haben
ich habe heute eine nachricht gehört in
der tagesschau dass herr altmaier und
sich gegen ende bis ostern dann
vielleicht ja makel dinge vorstellen
dass es wieder so einen kleinen anlauf
gibt aber wenn ich zurückschaue habe ich
meine zweifel nicht die nächsten monate
oder sagen wir wirken mit beginn der
pandemie waren es von mir von der
bundesregierung ein hilfloser
aktionismus ohne jeglicher strategie
egal in welche richtung es geht mir
graut es jetzt schon davor dass kitas
und schulen auf machen was ich für
richtig finde aber wahrscheinlich wieder
ohne konzept weil sie dann wieder in den
schulbussen und in den u bahn so dass
die dritte leiden müssen meinen sie nein
so dass sie noch länger geschlossen
haben müssen da stark eine strategie
dahinter ist dass man gut vorgesorgt
haben eine viele zumindest tischer
auseinander gestellt zählte
belüftungsanlagen große investiert und
in den schulen saß meistens halt ein
bisschen anders aus
manchmal doch ganz kurz auch beim sie
die frage gehen sie davon aus dass ihre
kartbahn am leben bleibt wären sie
vielleicht besser gefahren sie hätten
die kartbahn dicht gemacht
das ist sehen wir das beste gewesen
jetzt nicht zu machen alle leute
rauszuwerfen dass das lager alle zu
vermieten muss in unserer gegend auch
leicht findet noch industrie gefördert
haben wir auch viele leute in bezirks
amazon würde sich wohl freuen würde ich
aber nicht tun meint wieder öffnen egal
wann wenn ich dafür jederzeit sterben
und da ich weiter lesen wieder öffnen
aber eigentlich möchte ich ihnen ganz
deutlich sagen für mich ist dass ich mit
53 jahren normalerweise immer ein
bisschen voraus langen kann ich kann
nicht ich kann mir vorstellen dass wir
im april/mai vielleicht davon dürften
dann machen lauf aber mein geschäft
kommt zu zwei dritteln von oktober bis
jetzt april soll stand mit dem oktober
wieder zu scheren
ich glaube ihre geschichte nicht 25 von
von einem großteil der ist
wirtschaft bis zum sommer zu machen wird
nicht funktionieren dass da kommen wir
gleich drauf ein bis drei jahre dauern
wenn ich zwei bis drei jahre jedes
hinter geschäft fuß per bus dann sang
sie es mir leicht weil dann mach ich
irgendwas ohne dass man alle ich glaube
alle wünschen allen dreien dass das
funktioniert dass es so schnell wie
möglich eröffnet er hat es mit in der
hand das zu beschließen wir alle offen
irgendwie auf eine perspektive auf einen
stufenplan ich glaube das würde schon
ein bisschen ruhe reinbringen weil es
eine perspektive bringen danke danke
herr gegners danke hartmann auch und ja
hoffentlich ist das ein oder andere so
ein drink nicht gewesen dass es doch
noch mal beschleunigt wird